ça y est le powerpoint tout marche
ça a l'air marcher mais chers collègues
nous débutons nos travaux de ce jour par
une audition conjointe consacrée aux
grandes évolutions démographiques en
France et alors conséquence sur le
système de protection sociale
non pas parce quitter la salle il y a
pas de
trouveront pas ouvrage ne prendrons pas
non mais c'est un sujet très important
ça faisait longtemps qu'on voulait
lancer cette cette édition
je précise qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo il s'agit d'un sujet
d'intérêt majeur pour notre commission
et d'une occasion d'essayer d'anticiper
les grandes tendances et les besoins
qu'entraîneront les évolutions
démographiques en matière sociale
l'examen de la récente réforme des
retraites nous a montré à la fois
comment la démographie ne peut être
esquivée par le législateur et comment
les pouvoirs publics ont tendance à
nager que lorsqu'il se trouve au pied du
mur
d'un mur
or les grandes mutations sont à l'oeuvre
et pourrait percuter notre système
social dans toutes ses facettes nous
voyons notamment que l'indice de
fécondité diminue que la population
continue de vieillir que néanmoins
l'espérance de vie semble stagner voire
diminuer depuis quelques années et que
l'arrivée des populations émigrées
elle-même diverses à des conséquences
internes économiques et en termes de
cohésion nationale pour nous éclairer
sur ces sujets nous recevons madame
Christelle Colin directrice des
statistiques démographiques et sociales
de l'Insee ainsi une nationale de la
statistique et des études économiques
madame Emmanuel cambois et Monsieur
Laurent tout Lemont tous deux directeurs
de recherche à Lynette qui est
l'Institut national des études
démographiques je vous remercie madame
non mesdames et messieurs d'avoir
accepté cette invitation et je vous
invite à nous brosser dans un propos
liminaire un grand tableau des yeux
enfin non un tableau des grandes
évolutions démographiques de la
population française et des principaux
éléments que nous devrions avoir
l'esprit en tant que législateur en
matière sociale et ensuite vous devez
répondre aux questions que ne manquerons
pas de vous poser nos collègues et
peut-être madame Colin
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et à tous merci pour votre pardon
excusez-moi merci pour pour votre
invitation donc je vais commencer par
revenir sur les grandes tendances
démographiques puis mes collègues de
Liné de vos comptes plus précisément les
questions de fécondité et de
vieillissement de la population qui font
partie en effet des
grandes questions importantes à
documenter
donc la situation démographique en
France la situation des graphiques
actuelles je vais commencer par
l'actuelle et ensuite j'évoquerai des
projections de population que la
situation démographique actuelle en
France est marquée par plusieurs faits
marquants tout d'abord donc une
population de qui atteint 68 millions
d'habitants en janvier 2023 qui continue
de croître mais à un rythme plus lent
que par le passé donc une hausse de 0,3%
en 2022 après
0,4% en 2021 03% en 2020 et on était à
des tendances un petit peu plus des taux
de croissance un peu plus élevés avant
ensuite un solde naturel donc le sol de
naturel c'est l'excédent des naissances
sur les décès
oui c'est assez spectaculaire je me
passe ce commentaire voilà donc vous
voyez que l'excédent naturel qui est
donc l'écart entre les deux courbes est
à son plus bas niveau en 2022 son plus
bas niveau depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
ceci tient à deux raisons d'une part une
baisse des naissances depuis 2015 à part
un petit rebond en 2021 et une hausse
des décès depuis le milieu des années
2010 cette hausse des décès elle vient
d'abord de l'arrivée des générations
nombreuses du babyboom à des âges de
plus forte mortalité
et puis il y a eu en 2020 21
un excédent particulier de mortalité
liée à l'épidémie de covid-19 et en 2022
à la fois la poursuite de la pandémie en
début d'année et puis des épisodes de
canicule et des épisodes de grippe
également notamment en fin d'année qui
ont
soutenu entre guillemets la mortalité
donc l'espérance
et l'espérance de vie en 2022 reste
inférieure à son niveau de 2019 du fait
de ces événements particuliers entre
2020 et 2022 mais pendant la décennie
précédente entre 2010 et 2019
l'espérance de vie avec quand même
continué d'augmenter toutefois moins que
par le passé
et la troisième composante
l'autre composante de l'évolution de la
population c'est le sol de migratoires
donc le solde des entrées sur le
territoire et des sorties du territoire
et qui lui est estimé à plus 160000 de
manière provisoire en 2022 il était d'un
peu moins 100 000 en moyenne par an sur
les 10 dernières années et il fluctue
surtout beaucoup d'une année sur l'autre
voilà il aurait un peu tendance à
remonter depuis 2017 mais plutôt du fait
d'un ralentissement des sorties que
d'une autre des entrées
et une autre tendance très importante à
mentionner vous l'avez mentionné dans
votre propos introductif madame la
Présidente c'est le vieillissement de la
population donc au 1er janvier 2023 21%
de la population
21% des habitants étaient âgés de 65 ans
et plus et 10 % de 65 de 75 ans et plus
donc ce phénomène de vieillissement il
est pas nouveau il s'observe depuis une
trentaine d'années d'abord avec
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie et
puis ensuite il s'accélère avec
l'arrivée aux âges élevés de des
générations nombreuses du baby-boom
donc là ce sont les tendances récentes
et sur la base de ces tendances récentes
et d'hypothèse sur leur prolongation ou
non ainsi que de consultations d'experts
l'Insee a établi en 2021 des projections
de population jusqu'en 2070 donc c'est
un exercice que l'INSEE réalise tous les
5 ans
donc il y a divers scénarios de
projection qui ont été établies
très rapidement un scénario central donc
à chaque fois on fait des hypothèses sur
la fécondité l'espérance de vie et sur
les migration et puis ensuite des
variantes avec des hypothèses ou tout
basses de fécondité de mortalité et de
sol de migratoires je vais pas les
détailler à complètement puisque au
total on a beaucoup de scénarios mais
peut-être ce que l'on peut retenir en
synthèse du scénario central
c'est que jusqu'en 2035 donc on aurait
un sol de naturel donc c'est toujours
l'écart entre la courbe des naissances
et la courbe des décès qui resterait
positif donc on aurait encore plus
toujours plus de naissances que de décès
malgré la forte hausse des décès du fait
des toujours des générations nombreuses
du baby-boom donc ce soldat naturel
combiné à un solde migratoire positif
fait que la population continuerait à
augmenter toutefois moins que par le
passé et ensuite à partir de 2035
toujours dans ce scénario central des
projections le nombre de décès
dépasserait le nombre des naissances
donc la population continuerait de
croître mais du seul fait du sol de
migratoire
et selon les hypothèses que l'on a
retenu
ça se voit plus mieux sur la
celle-là d'après et selon les hypothèses
que l'on a retenu à partir de 2044 voilà
on aurait plutôt une légère décroissance
de la population et donc le sol de
migratoire ne suffirait plus à avec les
hypothèses retenues le solde migratoire
ne suffirait plus à combler l'excédent
de décès sur les naissances
un autre résultat très important de ces
projections c'est le la poursuite du
vieillissement de la population là aussi
je trouve que la figure est assez
parlante donc vous avez la pyramide des
âges en gris celle la pyramide des âges
actuels et en rouge la pyramide des âges
projetées en 2070 et en fait donc la
population totale en 2070 est assez
proche en nombre d'habitants de la
situation actuelle mais très différente
en termes de composition puisque en gros
il y aurait selon toujours ce scénario
central
un plus de 5 millions de personnes de 75
ans ou plus en plus et à peu près 5
millions de personnes de 60 ans ou moins
en moins voilà donc une pyramide des
âges qui s'élargit beaucoup vers le haut
aux élevés qui seraient ici en bas aux
âges jaunes
voilà donc ce qui fait en fait deux
composantes du vieillissement à la fois
un élargissement par le haut et une
réduction par le bas
et donc de ce fait la part des personnes
de 65 ans et plus dans la population
donc qui était passé de 16% à 21 % entre
en grosso modo 2000 et 2021 continuerait
à augmenter ça serait à 26% en 2040 et
pourrait encore continuer à augmenter
jusqu'à 29% en 2070 et la part des
personnes de 80 ans ou plus
accélèreraient également à partir de
à partir de à cet horizon de projection
alors il faut avoir en tête un élément
important c'est que comme je vous ai dit
dans les projections il y a un scénario
central il y a des variantes mais il y a
un phénomène qui qu'on dit inéluctable
en fait c'est ce vieillissement de la
population parce que jusqu'à 2040 en
fait quel que soit les hypothèses on a
en fait très peu d'écart par exemple là
sur l'indicateur qui représenté qui est
le ratio de dépendance démographique
c'est-à-dire la part des personnes de 65
ans en plus
le nombre de personnes de 65 ans ou plus
rapporter pour 100 personnes de 20 à 64
ans et donc vous voyez sur les courbes
que en fait les courbes des différentes
variantes sont très rapprochées très
très proche et une des autres jusqu'à
2040 donc quel que soit les hypothèses
en fait on a une une hausse importante
de ce rapport de dépendance
démographique qui passerait de 37
personnes de 65 ans ou plus pour 100
personnes 20 à 74 ans en 2021 à environ
50 en 2040 et ça quel que soit les
scénarios
par contre après 2040 en fonction des
hypothèses de fécondité de mortalité etc
là pour y avoir une une différenciation
c'est à dire ça pourrait être plus
marqué ce vieillissement pour être
encore continué à s'accentuer ou être un
peu plus limité à l'horizon 2070
donc évidemment ce vieillissement comme
vous l'avez rappelé c'est un enjeu
majeur pour les politiques sociales dans
les dans les prochaines années que ce
soit en matière de retraite en matière
de prise en charge de la dépendance en
matière de logement avec les questions
de maintien à domicile ou de vie en
établissement avec aussi une demande de
logement qui va probablement évoluer ce
qu'on observe également c'est en partie
lieuvillissement mais pas seulement
c'est une baisse de la taille moyenne
des ménages et donc voilà ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut adapter des logements
le besoin logement peut être un peu
différent
donc ce sont ici les tendances et les
projections nationales ça peut se
décliner au niveau des territoires
donc au niveau des territoires on a des
évolutions démographiques et une
structure de la population qui sont
assez contrastées aujourd'hui par
exemple la structure par âge de la
population varie nettement d'un
département à l'autre vous avez à gauche
la part des personnes de 60 ou plus et à
droite la personne la part des personnes
de moins de 25 ans la population est
plus âgée dans la majorité des
départements d'un grand quart sud-ouest
plus quelques départements
rouges foncé à gauche
voilà
à l'inverse à droite vous avez une
population un peu plus jeune dans le
nord de la France et puis une situation
également très contrastée dans les dans
les doms avec des départements jeunes
comme la Guyane et Mayotte et plus âgée
en Martinique en Guadeloupe notamment le
Nord est plutôt jeune
la grande cour
la grande couronne de l'Île-de-France
aussi voilà vous faites des enfants mais
vous avez une espérance de vie un peu un
peu moins favorable que dans d'autres
territoires
voilà
ces territoires connaissent aussi des
évolutions de population contrastées
donc à gauche vous avez le taux de
variation de la annuelle de la
population par département sur les 5 6
dernières années et donc les
départements en rouge se sont ceux qui
ont des croissances de population les
plus élevées
et donc c'est forte croissance
démographique elle se concentre autour
de Paris le long de la façade atlantique
et en gros dans le couloir Rodania voilà
et puis en bleu alors ces petits parce
que c'est souvent des départements moins
peuplés donc ce sont les départements
qui soient perdent déjà de la population
soit en décroissance faible et donc qui
se situe notamment dans le car nord-est
et puis au centre et dans le Massif
Central
si on regarde maintenant en projection
puisque c'est les projections nationales
que je vous ai indiqué elles sont
également déclinées au niveau
territorial au niveau régional et
départemental
et donc pour faire ces projections il
faut à la fois faire des hypothèses sur
la fécondité la mortalité les entrées
sorties sur le territoire français mais
aussi les entrées et sorties des
différents départements donc les
migrations internes au territoire
français donc ça rend compte aussi de
l'attractivité relative des territoires
au sein de la France et donc au niveau
national comme je voulais indiquer tout
à l'heure on aurait un pic de population
en 2044 voilà dans le scénario central
et à gauche vous voyez l'année qui
serait l'année du pic de population
suivant les départements et donc il y a
des départements ou en fait ce pic de
population a déjà été atteint
c'est-à-dire départements qui sont
de la population diminue et va continuer
de diminuer c'est en gros ceux qui sont
les plus claires et puis en plus foncé
c'est des départements qui n'ont pas
encore connu le pic
et la situation va se retourner ou alors
c'est les départements très foncés où on
la population continuerait encore
d'augmenter selon nos projections à
l'horizon 2070 mais donc des situations
assez contrastées
on peut aussi regarder le vieillissement
de la population et donc il se trouve à
droite et donc le vieillissement de la
population il est évidemment partout sur
tous les territoires mais plus ou moins
marqués notamment en fonction des
situations de départ et donc le quart
sud-ouest et puis la Martinique et la
Guadeloupe atteindrait les parts de
personnes âgées les plus les plus élevés
et donc ça signifie également que les
les défis liés à la prise en charge de
du grand âge sont évidemment variables
selon les territoires
je vais maintenant laisser ma parole à
mes collègues de l'hymen
je crois que c'est Laurent qui
se coupe
merci donc bonjour alors
parmi les questions que vous nous avez
posées un certain nombre de portes sur
le niveau de la fécondité donc comme
Christelle Colin l'a dit la baisse des
naissances et la hausse des décès qui
paraissent symétrique sur les graphiques
correspondent en fait à deux phénomènes
tout à fait différents la hausse des
décès elle vient principalement du fait
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une situation
de déséquilibre et le nombre de
personnes âgées va augmenter et le
nombre de décès va augmenter c'est tout
à fait certain
Christelle Colin nous a dit que c'était
inéluctable c'est vraiment quelque chose
de de très important à garder en mémoire
en revanche le nombre de naissances lui
il évolue depuis une cinquantaine
d'années depuis la fin du baby-boom avec
une période de hausse pendant les années
80 puis une période de baisse au début
des années 90 une hausse depuis le
milieu des années 90 et une nouvelle
baisse depuis des années 2010 baisse qui
s'est accentué depuis cinq ans donc la
baisse c'est effectivement assez
spectaculaire depuis 2014 même si avec
la crise du covid il y a eu et on le
verra tout de suite dans beaucoup de
pays un changement de tendance ou une
interruption des tendances donc d'une
part il y a une baisse qui est marquée
des naissances mais d'autre part si on
regarde les évolutions de puis 50 ans le
nombre de naissances en France c'est à
peu près constant on est aujourd'hui
plutôt à un niveau bas mais on reste
dans disons l'intervalle de nombre de
naissances qu'on observe depuis 50 ans
et donc
aujourd'hui même si les trois premiers
mois de 2023 ont montré une baisse assez
marquée ça me paraît prématuré de dire
qu'on est sur une tendance longue de
baisse même si et là j'ai mis un
graphique avec des comparaisons
européennes avec également un ou deux
pays non européens notamment les
États-Unis on voit que la crise
économique de 2008 a entraîné dans
beaucoup de pays de l'OCDE une baisse
importante des naissances et en gros
tous les pays où la fécondité était
élevée ont vu leur fécondité baissée à
partir de 2010 et la France qui est en
rouge sur ce graphique a eu plutôt une
baisse retardée et modérée par rapport
aux autres pays où la fécondité est
élevée et puis la moyenne européenne qui
est dans la courbe bleue épaisse était
beaucoup plus bas de l'ordre 1,5 enfants
par femme et aujourd'hui entre 1,5 1,6
enfants parce que il y a des pays
notamment dans la partie sud de l'Europe
l'Italie l'Espagne qui sont ici en
orange et puis en noir pointillés qui
restent avec des niveaux de fécondité
très bas vous voyez 1,2 enfin par femme
c'est un niveau de fécondité qui n'est
pas du tout du même ordre que 1,8 ou 1,7
avec
disons qu'avec 1,8 enfants et un peu de
migration il faudrait plus de 150 ans
pour que la population diminue de moitié
alors que avec une fécondité de 1,2
enfants la fécondité elle diminue de
moitié pratiquement tous les 50 ans donc
c'est pas du tout le même rythme des
évolutions de population le rythme du
vieillissement sont tout à fait
différents donc aujourd'hui en France on
est à un niveau de fécondité qui reste
assez élevé à la fois en termes de
dynamique de long terme et on l'a vu la
population dans les projections de
l'INSEE diminue à horizon de 2070 mais
diminue relativement peu aux âges
adultes et pour les enfants alors que
dans d'autres pays les projections
conduisent à des diminutions beaucoup
plus importantes
alors sur le court terme là je vous ai
mis volontairement un très grand nombre
de pays pour vous montrer que les
situations sont à la fois très diverses
et assez contrasté en termes de tendance
donc vous avez ici les naissances par
mois depuis janvier 2020 qui sont
transformés par les démographes de
l'Institut de Vienne en indice
conjoncturel de fécondité c'est-à-dire
le nombre d'enfants par femme au cours
de la vie si le niveau de la fécondité
restait constant et qui sont décaisonnés
puisque dans beaucoup de pays il y a un
mouvement saisonniers des naissances qui
vient perturber d'une certaine façon les
évolutions donc quand on compare les
pays à cette tôle on voit donc envers la
France vous voyez avec
au début 2021 une baisse importante qui
est apparue 9 mois après le premier
confinement et on le voit dans beaucoup
de pays le début de l'épidémie de covid
qui a entraîné évidemment une hausse de
mortalité très importante a aussi
entraîné une baisse du nombre des
naissances dans beaucoup beaucoup de
pays 9 mois après mais ça n'est pas vrai
dans tous les pays et par exemple ses
parents en Allemagne par exemple il y a
pas eu de baisse ils avaient eu des
décès un peu plus précoces il y a pas eu
de baisse à ce moment-là ensuite après
cette baisse importante du premier
confinement donc grosso modo il y a eu
plutôt une hausse dans les mois qui ont
suivi dans beaucoup de pays alors soit
un rattrapage soit un effet cocooning
les gens étaient chez eux et puis une
fois le traumatisme passé et surtout
quand la situation économique c'est pas
trop détériorée ou bien pour des gens
qui perdaient leur emploi c'était
l'occasion peut-être de faire un enfant
donc il y a eu ce phénomène en 2021 et
puis dans un certain nombre de pays en
2022 il y a une baisse très importante
des naissances c'est vraiment en
Allemagne c'est vraiment en Suède c'est
vrai au Japon et cette baisse importante
elle est expliquée par les démographes
de ces pays par une conséquence possible
alors ce sont uniquement des
corrélations macroéconomiques donc on a
un peu du mal à voir une réalité mais
les démographes n'arrivent pas à mettre
ça en lien avec des évolutions
socio-économiques par contre il y a eu
les rappels de vaccination il y a eu
dans beaucoup de pays l'idée que les
femmes enceintes étaient un une
population centrale pour la vaccination
et que
il fallait mieux être déjà vacciné avant
d'entamer une grossesse et donc leur
interprétation c'est qu'il y a eu un
retard important des naissances alors
qui est rattrapé dans certains pays
pendant d'autres alors qu'en France on a
plutôt eu des informations
erronées sur les risques liés à la
vaccination qui était tout à fait
erronée mais il y a pas eu de liens fait
entre la grossesse et la vaccination en
France aussi fortement que dans ces pays
et de fait on ne voit pas en 2002 une
diminution donc voyez par rapport à la
question que vous nous posiez de savoir
pourquoi la fécondité BC autant et
pourquoi elle était aussi basse j'aurais
tendance à dire la fécondité n'est pas
si basse et elle ne baisse pas tellement
et on voit que même si la baisse
continue quand même depuis on voit bien
depuis 2021 on est quand même à une
baisse qui est de l'ordre de 7%, on
serait sur le long terme ici à un niveau
de fécondité qui serait de l'ordre de
1,7 peut-être même un petit peu en
dessous enfin par femme si la baisse se
prolongeait dans les mois à venir mais
j'aurais tendance à dire que on n'est
pas encore dans cette situation
où disons on aurait une baisse marquée
et durable des naissances en France
maintenant le fait que dans les autres
pays le niveau est plus bas et baisse
également peut inciter à dire que
peut-être que l'exception française
pourrait aussi prendre fin d'une
certaine façon et ça me permet de faire
la transition sur les questions que vous
nous avez posées sur les des
explications possibles alors il y a bien
sûr les explications en termes
économique de fragilité économique de
conciliation entre vie familiale vie
professionnelle avec les questions du
nombre de places en accueil pour les
jeunes enfants de moins de 3 ans mais ça
ce sont vraiment plutôt des tendances
longues qui n'expliquent pas des
évolutions de très court terme
donc alors vous avez posé également des
questions sur les questions sur
l'infertilité je sais pas si j'y
répondrai aux questions ou on vous
enverra peut-être des réponses écrites
parce que je sais pas dans quel détail
vous voulez qu'on aille sur ces
questions alors concernant la politique
sociale et familiale
on peut dire que les effets sont
difficiles à mesurer par exemple depuis
2014 il y a eu des changements dans les
politiques d'allocations familiales qui
ont plutôt touché les personnes aux
revenus les plus élevées et la baisse a
eu lieu dans tous les niveaux de revenus
à peu près donc on ne peut pas dire
les gens les plus riches ont été touchés
par certaines mesures et du coup leur
fécondité à plus baissé que les autres
ce qui aurait été la méthode
économétrique disons d'estimer un effet
direct mais d'une part les personnes qui
ont des revenus élevés c'est pas un
changement des allocations qui va leur
faire renoncer avoir des enfants donc
c'est bien normal que l'effet direct
soit faible ou voire inexistant par
contre il peut y avoir ce qu'on appelle
un effet de halo c'est-à-dire des
personnes qui ne sont pas concernées par
une mesure peuvent craindre que à
l'avenir elle pourrait être touchée par
d'autres mesures mais ça ce sont des
craintes sur le long terme qui sont tout
à fait impossibles à mesurer sachant que
globalement les couples changent assez
souvent ma vie quand au nombre d'enfants
qui veulent et avoir un enfant ça veut
dire avoir des relations sexuelles en
arrêtant la contraception pour avoir une
grossesse tout de suite donc c'est
vraiment une décision qui se prend dans
l'intimité des couples et à ce moment-là
on se demande pas tellement si la
planète se réchauffe si on va voir des
allocations enfin c'est un peu d'autres
questions qui se posent dans la les
décisions
intimes des couples et donc la seule
relation un peu solide qu'on peut mettre
en évidence quand on compare les pays
entre eux c'est que une politique
familiale solide et stable et notamment
qui permet au couple d'avoir deux
salaires et notamment au maire de se
remettre au travail assez rapidement
après la naissance d'un enfant avec des
perspectives de carrière qui ne sont pas
trop détériorés sont disons
l'explication la plus solide quand on
compare les pays entre eux sur le long
terme
pour expliquer le niveau de la fécondité
qui est vous l'avez vu assez élevé en
France par rapport aux autres aux autres
pays
alors il y avait d'ailleurs une question
que vous avez posée sur les différentes
sociales de fécondité on observe une
courbe qu'on appelle courbe en U avec
une fécondité plus élevée en bas et en
haut de la hiérarchie des revenus ou des
positions sociales et une fécondité plus
basse au milieu donc la deux éléments
très rapidement d'une part c'est tout à
fait conforme à la théorie économique il
y a d'une part un coup d'opportunité
mais plus vous avez des bonnes
perspectives de carrière plus le fait
d'avoir un enfant est dangereux et donc
vous perdez en opportunité et donc les
femmes qui sont tout en bas de la
hiérarchie des salaires et des
professions d'une certaine façon elles
ont peu à perdre à faire des enfants
parce qu'elles sont déjà dans une
situation qui est très défavorable donc
ça ça explique la fécondité est plus
élevée en bas de la hiérarchie des
revenus et des positions sociales et à
l'inverse il y a l'effet revenu qui fait
que il y a un coût à élever des enfants
et même si en France beaucoup de coûts
notamment les contraintes en termes de
logement en termes d'éducation des
enfants qui sont des contraintes très
fortes sur le long terme dans beaucoup
de pays sont moins marqués en France on
peut dire en termes de de coûts
d'éducation des enfants on est plutôt
disons on compense plutôt
plus les coûts mais ça n'empêche que
quand les parents sont éduqués des
enfants font des études longues donc ça
coûte plus cher et cet effet revenu fait
que quand les personnes ont suffisamment
de revenu on le voit d'ailleurs dans
certaines aides ou familles sont
directement orientées pour compenser le
coût des enfants de parents qui ont des
revenus élevés un enfant de riche ça
coûte plus cher ça part en vacances à
une fin ça a une chambre seule ça fait
des étudiants donc ça coûte plus cher à
la nation c'est aussi un investissement
de long terme pour la nation mais
toujours est-il que cet effet revenu est
important en France et il a tendance à
gagner du terrain dans beaucoup de pays
d'Europe où des disons les aides de
politique familiales et sociales sont
moins marquées et du coup l'effet revenu
prend de l'importance dans beaucoup de
pays d'Europe où la fécondité se
stabilise surtout en haut de la
hiérarchie des revenus et en France ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que depuis 14 la
baisse est relativement uniforme l'Insee
a un échantillon démographique permanent
qui permet de mettre en regard les
positions sociales précises des
individus et leur comportement de
fécondité c'est un outil extrêmement
précieux pour suivre les évolutions des
différences sociales à court terme et on
ne voit pas de différence sociale très
marquées maintenant derrière cette
courbe en U il y a une hétérogité très
forte donc là aussi à une publication de
l'Insee mais qui est un peu complexe qui
met en regard le pays de naissance
c'est-à-dire est-ce que les parents sont
nés en France ou est-ce qu'ils sont nés
à l'étranger le niveau de diplôme est-ce
que les parents ont un niveau de diplôme
élevé ou un niveau de diplôme faible et
le niveau de revenu des parents au
moment où il décide ou non de faire des
enfants et il y a des interactions très
complexes pour dire les choses
simplement parmi les gens qui ont des
revenus élevés il y a relativement peu
de différence selon le niveau diplôme le
pays de naissance par contre en bas de
la hiérarchie des revenus il y a des
grandes différences avec d'un côté des
immigrés peu diplômés pauvres qui ont
une fécondité élevée et d'un autre côté
des personnes nées en France avec des
diplômes faibles et des diplômés levés
pardon et des revenus faibles qui ont
une fécondité très basse donc ça ça
répond à des contraintes de des
organisations sociales et notamment on
voit qu'il y a une augmentation des
familles monoparentales en France plutôt
en bas de la hiérarchie des diplômes
donc il y a une interaction compliquée
entre le niveau de la fécondité qu'on
mesure à un moment donné et puis les
positions dans la hiérarchie sociale
mais disons que s'il y a un message à
retenir c'est que en France par rapport
à d'autres pays les comportements sont
relativement homogènes et des évolutions
sont relativement homogènes
par rapport encore une fois à d'autres
pays d'Europe
je vais peut-être passer la parole à
Emmanuel pour nous parler du phénomène
qui est quand même le phénomène central
à venir sur le vieillissement de la
population
dont vous avez probablement entendu
beaucoup parler alors je vais peut-être
commencer par expliquer ce qui est
derrière cet indicateur pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de méprise et qui ait une bonne
compréhension de ce qu'il représente
l'indicateur repose sur une mesure de la
santé en fait il y a autant
d'indicateurs
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé que de
mesure de la Santé et celui qu'on publie
régulièrement que l'unité publique
chaque année que le Eurostat compare
entre tous les pays c'est un indicateur
qui repose sur une mesure des
limitations dans les activités qu'on
fait habituellement donc c'est un
indicateur qu'on pourrait dire plutôt
d'incapacité que de bonnes santé c'est
en quoi la santé la mauvaise santé vient
gêner vos activités ça peut être des
activités professionnelles dans les âges
actifs et dans l'usage d'employabilité
et ça peut être des activités du
quotidien au domicile du quotidien soin
personnel quand on arrive à des âges
plus élevés ou à des personnes
vulnérable donc ici on a cet indicateur
d'espérance de vie avec et sans
limitation d'activité appelée espérance
de vie en bonne santé et je vous ai
représenté ici l'évolution qu'on peut
obtenir grâce à une enquête européenne
dans le volet français fourni ces
données de limitation d'activité vous
voyez à gauche les hommes à droite à
droite les femmes c'est l'espérance de
vie à 65 ans alors première chose qu'on
peut noter c'est le fait que l'espérance
de vie à 65 ans fluctue donc on a vu
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait peut-être
un ralentissement de l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie chez les femmes un
rattrapage des hommes par rapport aux
femmes ce qu'on peut voir dans les
grands âges c'est qu'il y a une
peut-être une diminution certaines
années mais un rattrapage l'année
d'après et on se rend compte qu'en fait
la mortalité aujourd'hui et et se réduit
davantage aux grands âges que aux âges
plus jeunes ou de jeunes actifs et que
assez grand âge il y a une certaine
vulnérabilité de la population qui est
beaucoup plus sensible pour ces
personnes vulnérables à des épisodes
sanitaires donc vous avez tous en tête
l'épisode de la canicule de 2003 nous
avons tous en tête les événements
récents de crise sanitaire mais il faut
savoir que chaque année il y a des
événements sanitaires qui sont la grippe
les coups de chaud les coups de froid
les gastro et que tous ces événements
viennent en quelque sorte accélérées
pour certaines personnes aux grands âges
le risque de décéder et le décès et
qu'on observe ces fluctuations qui sont
largement commentées dans la presse à
chaque fois qu'elles arrivent mais qui
finalement sont changeantes d'une année
sur l'autre avec des ampleurs de
quelques mois alors une fois que j'ai
dit ça on peut regarder au centre les
couleurs les plus
nonacées on va dire pleine les bars
pleines montrent que l'espérance de vie
sans incapacité chez les femmes par
exemple à une tendance à une
augmentation quelle que soit la
fluctuation de l'espérance de vie donc
on a une tendance avec une évolution pas
très importante mais plutôt une
augmentation des années de vie sans
limitation chez les femmes à 65 ans au
sein de l'espérance de vie et vous
pouvez voir en miroir que chez les
femmes on a une réduction de ces années
de vie avec des limitations la partie
hachée et qui donc il y a ce qu'on
appelle une compression des années de
mauvaise santé ou d'incapacité chez les
femmes à ces âge-là chez les hommes la
lecture est un peu plus complexe comme
vous pouvez le voir la partie foncée
fluctue fluctue comme fluctue
l'espérance de vie et on ne peut pas
conclure directement comme on le peut
pour les femmes à une compression nette
ou à une expansion nette des années
d'incapacité chez les hommes on voit en
tout cas que sa fluctue comme je disais
tout à l'heure au rythme de la
fluctuation de l'espérance de vie et il
sent que selon les événements sanitaires
chez les hommes on a davantage de perte
quelques années à la fois d'année avec
des incapacités et à la fois des années
sans incapacité chez les femmes les
événements sanitaires semblent être
plutôt des pertes d'années avec des
incapacités donc ce qu'on appelle un
effet de Moisson c'est-à-dire que les
crises sanitaires vont emporter des
femmes déjà en situation d'incapacité
chez les hommes c'est un peu moins un
peu moins clair dans ce sens là donc
difficile de connaître l'impact exact de
de ces fluctuations tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui
l'état de santé et les projections qu'on
peut faire du nombre de personnes qui
ontront besoin d'aide dans leur années
de vie aux grands âges sont compliqués à
faire parce qu'elles sont basées oui il
y a quelque chose que je comprends pas
bien dites parce que homme vous avez
avec
uniforme et chez les femmes on a avec
qui gris clair et sans qui est assez
quand on regarde le tableau on a
l'impression que chez les femmes
l'espérance de vie avec l'imitation de
l'activité augmente ah non parce que
[Musique]
en haut vous avez homme avec et 21 est
en bas 2021 et c'est bien ça mais quand
vous regardez femmes avec femmes sans
en 21 on a l'impression que le gris unit
augmente et le haché baisse or vous nous
avez dit l'inverse mais est-ce qu'il y a
pas est-ce qu'il y a pas une inversion
des titres au dessus là avec et sans ah
oui avec et pardon oui oui tout à fait
ah oui c'est pour ça que ça me perturbe
je suis désolé c'est pas grave si vous
nous le renvoyez je vous remercie pour
votre vigilance
tu le lis le bas le bas c'est 2021 mais
c'est le avec sang chez les femmes quand
tu le regardes comme ça on a
l'impression que en haut c'est 2010
mais non mais ça se dégrade pas parce
qu'en fait c'est inversé le gris et sans
et le voilà
c'est un graphique je peux pas vous le
changer
je ne comprenais pas bien en fait on va
retenir que le haché c'est les années
avec des limitations d'activité et le
plein au milieu ce sont des années de
bonne santé donc on est plutôt mieux
avec toutes mes humbles excuses pour
cette erreurs de cette coquille donc
pour reprendre donc maintenant que le
problème est clarifié je vais juste
peut-être prolongé avant qu'il y ait des
échanges de questions pour dire que en
fait toutes les projections qui sont
faites sur le nombre de personnes
dépendantes et on pourra y revenir à la
fois madame Colin moi-même sur les
projections vont dépendre de ces
évolutions de l'espérance de vie et de
ses évolutions des risques d'incapacité
et d'année d'incapacité qu'on peut
imputer on voit que les fluctuations
qu'on constate ici rendent complexe
d'exercice de projection et de Paris sur
comment vont évoluer ces années
d'incapacité
dire aussi que là je vous ai montré les
chiffres à 65 ans et un fait remarquable
qu'on a vu au début des années 2000
c'est que ces années d'incapacité dans
l'espérance de vie ont eu tendance à
augmenter dans la tranche d'âge 50 65
ans par rapport aux générations
précédentes on a une génération
[Musique]
et que ces maladies là sont très
sensibles à la fois à l'ensemble des
risques accumulés au cours de la vie et
à la fois à des contextes sociaux
économiques qui vont avoir une influence
très forte sur les expositions à ce type
de pathologie donc dans les termes
politiques mais on pourra en revenir
préciser que on montre avec vraiment des
chiffres et des preuves à la pluie que
la santé aux âges élevés est vraiment
liée à un continuum d'exposition tout au
long de la vie et relève à la fois des
parcours familiaux des parcours sociaux
des parcours professionnels qui sont
intriqués et qui viennent compliquer et
accumulées les risques pour les
situations de santé et qu'à ce titre les
politiques du Bien vieillir comme on dit
aujourd'hui sont en fait des politiques
extrêmement transversales à tous les
âges avec une attention forte à la
manière dont se déroule les parcours et
on revient à ce qui était évoqué par
Laurent toumont et Christelle Colin à
savoir que toutes les politiques
de vie active de conciliation vie
familiale vie professionnelle de lutte
contre la pauvreté sont des politiques
de prévention pour un vieillissement en
meilleure santé
écoutez merci beaucoup pour pour cette
présentation c'est
important pour nous en effet on lit
beaucoup d'articles on entend beaucoup
de choses mais d'avoir une vision
par vous qui êtes les spécialistes de
ces données démographiques de la
situation actuelle et des projections
qui sont faites alors Olivier Hainaut
s'inscrit pour poser des questions oui
merci madame la Présidente merci pour
ces explications très limpides sur
l'évolution de la population moi mes
observations et mes questions concernent
plus natalité et la branche famille on a
fait le choix dans ce pays quand même à
un moment donné de baisser les
prestations familiales en termes de PIB
puisque elles étaient de 1,5% du PIB
jusqu'en 2014 et elles ont baissées à
1,25 à 1,3 en 2004 de 2014 à aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça a un impact selon vous sur
la natalité par ailleurs il y a une
chose qui est aussi importante c'est le
recul de l'âge du premier enfant puisque
pour dire d'aller vite et passer de de
29 ans dans les années 2000 après ce que
31 ans aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est selon vous une
évolution durable et puis il y a le le
ton de do de fécondité qui qui chute et
on voit bien qu'en fait il chute pas
parmi les les les populations au niveau
de vie très modeste ou inférieur ou peu
il chute moins aussi parmi les gens très
aisés mais il chute particulièrement
dans la tranche de de revenus
intermédiaires et donc la question qui
nous est posée me semble-t-il mais
est-ce que si vous confirmez ça c'est
que on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
jeunes couples peuvent avoir ou de
couple d'âge de 30 ans plus tôt dans
cette catégorie de population un désir
d'enfant mais que ce désir d'enfant
et
il se concrétise à condition que le
sacrifice économique et social soit
relatif c'est à dire que moi il me
semble c'est empirique ce que je dis
mais que c'est une interrogation c'est à
dire que la question s'est posée c'est
qui est posée c'est d'avoir des enfants
mais est-ce que ça bouscule pas notre
vie et est-ce qu'on est capable
d'éduquer et d'élever nos enfants dans
un niveau de vie proche de celui que
qu'on a aujourd'hui est-ce que ça ne
est-ce que ça ne ne provoque pas une
forme de déclassement d'avoir deux trois
enfants ce qui est quand même une
question pour un certain nombre de
familles de niveau intermédiaire et tout
ça pose la question de de l'utilité de
la politique familiale qui est la
politique familiale n'est pas une
politique sociale et quelquefois on la
confondu la politique familiale est une
politique familiale et par ailleurs à
l'heure de cette remise à plat me
semble-t-il il y a aussi aujourd'hui
vous voyez toutes ces incertitudes elles
pèse sur la la politique familiale la
Cour des comptes a rejeté les comptes de
la branche famille aujourd'hui parce que
il y a à peu près
7,6% des des prestations qui sont mal
versées ou pas versées ou qui devraient
être versés ce qui est énorme puisque ça
représente plus de 6 milliards d'euros
donc voyez on est aussi à un moment où
on doit s'interroger sur le la question
du renouvellement des générations pas
seulement pour les politiques sociales
mais pour
comment dire le le
l'envie de de de transmettre la vie un
modèle aussi un modèle socioculturel un
peu c'est la question aussi de l'Europe
et de l'Occident qui est qui est posé de
ce que est-ce qu'on a envie de de
renouveler nos nos générations et donc
voilà toutes ces questions se pose quand
on regarde vos chiffres mais aussi quand
on regarde l'environnement qui nous
entoure je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente bonjour Merci
de vos communications peut-être quelques
questions une ou deux remarques on a eu
l'habitude de dire enfin moi j'étais un
peu en charge de ces questions de
Nathalie de politique familiale que la
ce qui vous aide d'exception française
ou une forme d'exposition française en
Europe c'était la conjugaison à la fois
d'un taux d'activité professionnelle des
femmes plus élevé que dans les pays
comparables et à la fois d'un taux de
natalité élevé et de ce point de vue la
politique familiale parce que c'est un
sujet politique qui caractérise la
France était celle essentiellement des
modes d'accueil de l'école de l'école à
3 ans de la gratuité de l'école à 3 ans
ce qui est loin d'être le cas dans
l'ensemble des pays et aujourd'hui
on s'interroge alors merci d'avoir dit
tout le monde merci d'avoir confirmé ce
que moi je pense c'est-à-dire que non
les familles aisées n'ont pas cessé de
faire des bébés quand on a passé dans un
location familiale de on a baissé de 25%
ou 50 % selon leur niveau de revenus les
allocations familiales et que c'est pas
l'élément déterminant mais j'entends
l'effet à l'eau effectivement j'entends
l'effet à l'eau mais c'est possible mais
c'est pas c'est pas mon avis
significatif pour décrire un phénomène
qui a un phénomène qui se passe partout
mais question sont alors notre collègue
à l'instant vient d'évoquer d'abord
l'âge de naissance du premier enfant qui
maintenant est effectivement au taux de
la 30 ans
qu'elle est quel est l'impact
quels sont les raisons alors peut-être
plus de la sociologie que la démographie
mais quels sont les raisons
ça c'est ma première question je pense
que ça tient pour ma part à l'insécurité
professionnels des femmes en partie
c'est à dire qu'elles ne sont pas
sécurisées dans le point avant 30 ans et
au fait que l'environnement
professionnel n'est pas toujours
favorable aux femmes enceintes et aux
maires de famille et ma deuxième
question tient à l'évolution cette plus
peut-être plus précis à l'évolution du
nombre de familles nombreuses parce que
comme le taux de fécondité est un taux
moyen
effectivement est-ce que le nombre de
familles nombreuses
diminue
de manière importante est-ce que c'est
lié à des politiques d'immigration
restrictives est-ce que sur des
prémoires vivants je dis bien parce que
sur les enfants nés de l'immigration le
modèle familial rejoint le modèle du
pays progressivement mais ce qu'on
observe voilà une diminution du nombre
d'enfants des familles nombreuses et une
baisse du nombre de familles nombreuses
et enfin est-ce que vous analysez en
fait il y a un décalage entre
les données statistiques parce que
d'abord elles sont plus dans la durée et
puis les données de la sociologie
empirique j'appellerais ça et ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on surestime le fait
qu'aujourd'hui chez les 20-35 ans par
exemple
quel est l'impact de l'écho anxiété
sur
les projets de famille de naissance
et d'un contexte psychosocial
défavorable aux enfants mais je pour
conclure je pense que les conditions
sociales et d'égalité femme homme reste
déterminante et dire à mes collègues que
la première des politiques Nathalie
c'est une politique qui consiste à
assurer aux femmes l'égalité
encore une autre question René Paul
Savary je vous laisserai répondre et
puis on fera une autre salle de question
prenez pas de ça varie notre rapporteur
je voudrais revenir je voudrais revenir
à votre graphique avec une courbe qui se
croise en 2045 entre les décès qui
augmentent considérablement contenu qui
est effectivement l'effet papy boom avec
une
avec une
population
âgée qui augmente donc un nombre de
décisions qu'un nombre de décents qui de
naissance qui diminue donc un croisement
à un moment
on pourrait penser qu'il y aura moins de
dépenses de retraite puisque il y a plus
de monde
mais il y a plus de cotisants il y a
plus de cotisants puisque il y a plus de
naissance donc
est-ce que on pourrait penser que le
système puisse s'équilibrer que par la
démographie
système de retraite
ça c'est une question
non non vous allez nous répondre
je vous laisse répondre il y avait deux
autres questions ou alors on prend tout
sur les comprenez deux autres questions
oui peut-être Daniel Chassain et Corinne
Humbert Daniel Chassain
merci madame la Présidente donc merci
et mesdames
mesdames et messieurs pour toutes ces
explications
donc vous nous avez expliqué le que le
nombre de personnes âgées augmentaient
au-delà de 65 ans
fortement en 2040 2050 2070 et donc vous
vous pouvez sûrement nous dire le nombre
d'actifs qui seront en extrapolant le
nombre d'actifs qui seront là en 2040 en
2050 et est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer
bien sûr une hypothèse du pourcentage
quel sera le pourcentage des actifs par
rapport au retraités en 2040 en 2050 ou
2070 nous voyons que dans les pays où il
y a une natalité plus plus basse vous
l'avez montré tout à l'heure depuis déjà
longtemps par exemple en Italie en
Espagne donc ils ont été obligés de
d'augmenter déjà depuis longtemps l'âge
de départ à la retraite donc c'était
pour savoir quel serait le nombre
d'actifs à peu près en 2040 2050 et quel
sera le rapport des cotisants merci par
rapport aux retraités
je vous propose de répondre et enfin une
autre une autre partie une autre tournée
oui
je vais commencer bien sûr en laissant
des éléments on peut peut-être commencer
par je vais commencer par la fin alors
celui avec les le ratio de dépendance
voilà voilà j'ai commencé par la fin
donc ici vous avez un graphique
qui présente pas tout à fait les actifs
et les retraités je vais compléter mais
qui déjà illustre les choses puisque
vous avez donc le nombre de personnes de
65 ans et plus donc âge auquel
essentiellement les personnes sont
retraitées par rapport au nombre de
personnes de 204 ans donc grosso modo
les âges d'activité professionnelle mais
c'est un premier réponse après je
reviendrai parce qu'on fait aussi des
projections de population active
elle-même donc j'étais un petit peu donc
voilà donc ça vous montre bien ce ratio
donc il était à peu près dans les années
aujourd'hui ou tout un peu moins de 40
donc à peu près 40 pour cent et donc il
augmente un peuple à peu près 50 à
l'horizon 2040 avec peu de variabilité
selon les hypothèses et après il peut
varier suivant les hypothèses de si on a
plus ou moins de fécondité parce qu'en
gros à l'horizon 2040 la fécondité je
joue pas voilà
compte non seulement de la démographie
du nombre de personnes mais aussi des
comportements d'activité puisque le taux
d'activité c'est pas c'est pas 100% il y
a des différences suivantes entre les
hommes et les femmes et puis les
différences selon l'âge voilà notamment
des évolutions alors avec une hausse du
taux d'activité des seniors ces
dernières années mais néanmoins on est
encore bien sûr pas des taux d'activités
de
100% voilà et donc dans ces projections
de population active ce que l'on voyait
c'était que donc le nombre d'actifs donc
aujourd'hui voilà en 2021 il y a à peu
près 30 millions d'actifs
donc le nombre d'actifs en fait ils
continuent dans nos projections et
continuer à augmenter
jusqu'en 2040 légèrement donc jolie
recherche mes chiffres
voilà donc plus plus 20 000 actifs par
an en moyenne jusqu'en 2040 et ensuite
la tendance s'inverserait à partir de
2040 avec une baisse du nombre d'actifs
voilà alors c'était des projections que
nous avons établies donc l'été dernier
donc avec les la législation en vigueur
l'été dernier et ce qu'on voit également
c'est que ces projections de population
active sont assez sensibles aux
hypothèses sur le sol de migratoires
forcément donc voilà donc ces
projections elles disent en fait
ce qui se passe un petit peu
spontanément après les politiques
publiques bien sûr peuvent infléchir un
certain nombre de choses alors
pas tout enfin voilà mais voilà et
notamment je crois qu'on avait mis une
variante
voilà et donc à l'horizon à l'horizon
2040 par exemple
voilà suivant qu'on prenait ce qu'on
prend un scénario avec un solde de
migratoire plus élevé ou un solde miroir
plus bas on a quand même entre les
scénarios un écart de plus d'un million
d'actifs voilà donc tout ça permet
d'illustrer
spontanément les tendances illustrer la
ce que produisent les tendances
démographiques après
les politiques publiques peuvent
infléchir un certain excusez-moi mais
parallèlement il y a le nombre d'actifs
qui augmentent jusque 2040 mais il y a
le nombre de retraités
en fait c'est pour ça que ça se corrige
pas après malgré tout
c'est ce qu'il fallait voir et après ça
va au contraire c'est pour ça que voilà
les deux sont intéressants je pense
d'avoir à la fois ce ratio dépendance
démographique et aussi c'est quand même
un contournel après pour la suite de
l'histoire je vous invite aussi vous le
savez bien à vous référer aux travaux du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
absolument puisque nous on fait voilà en
fait on fournit un peu les inputs
je vous rappelle qu'il donnait toujours
70 000 personnes en ce qui concerne le
solde migratoire et là vous êtes à 120
000 alors le seul de migrade c'est ce
qu'on a dans le scénario central les 70
000 le scénario eau est à 120 000 et on
a un scénario bas plus bas ça permet
d'encadrer un petit peu des possibles
merci voilà mais on a aussi des
scénarios
voilà qu'est-ce que je vais peut-être
reprendre sur la job première enfant on
va comme vous l'avez sur la structure
des familles sur les familles sur les
familles nombreuses alors sur les 10
dernières années leur paraly est resté
assez stable voilà donc ça avait
tendance à baisser par le par le passé
pardon trois enfants et plus
et donc par le passé la part avait eu
tendance à baisser mais entre 2011 et
2021 elle a la part restée stable et le
nombre d'enfants vivant dans des
familles nombreuses et rester assez
stables aussi entre 2011 et 2021 voilà
après on a une vous le savez une hausse
des familles monoparentales voilà ce qui
renvoie des questions aussi de
cruciales en termes de précarité en
termes d'activité féminine etc vous avez
commencé à aller voter
je vais vous
l'enverrai je vais voir si je le
retrouve et je complète combien 1,5
voilà et
juste sur la question j'ai laissé le
rang compléter sur toutes les questions
politiques alors sur les questions
politiques familiales c'est toujours
difficile bien sûr de démêler les de
démêler les effets par contre ce que sur
la question de l'impact sur les
différents évolutions par niveau de vie
ce qu'on a vu c'est que la baisse de la
fécondité donc depuis 2014 2015 elle a
touché tous les niveaux de vie
il y a une courbe en U mais cette courbe
en U elle est à un moment donné
voilà c'est à dire qu'il y a pas eu une
baisse beaucoup plus marquée pour
certains niveaux de vie parce que on a
regardé quand voilà avec la baisse de la
fécondité on s'est dit mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe est-ce que c'est plutôt tel
ou tel catégorie de la population on a
vu que c'était un peu diffus dans les
différents niveaux de vie diffus
aussi suivant les les diplômes etc voilà
donc c'était plutôt ça par contre un un
instant donné en effet on a une courbe
en U c'est à dire que plus d'enfants
pour les familles au plus bas niveau de
vie et plus pour les familles au plus
haut niveau de vie avec un creux au
milieu des niveaux de vie intermédiaire
voilà
et sur l'âge au premier enfant donc on a
des en effet il a augmenté on est à peu
on est à 30,8 je crois l'âge moyen la
maternité au premier enfant dans le
dernier bilan démographique et dans les
projections de population on a continué
à le faire augmenter
on a continué voilà on l'a fait
augmenter jusqu'à même 33 ans en lien
aussi avec les ce qui se passe aussi
dans les autres pays etc c'est à dire on
pense qu'elle ça peut encore augmenter
voilà après ce qu'on a vu alors là c'est
plutôt pour les générations qui ont
terminé leur vie féconde c'est que
malgré le recul de l'âge moyen la
maternité pour les générations qu'on
termine leur vie féconde la descendance
finale n'a pas n'a pas baissé quoi
mais je vais laisser je pense Laurent
compléter
merci alors très rapidement aussi
beaucoup de questions alors bon sur le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et le
financement de la branche famille là je
vous renvoie au rapport du Haut Conseil
de financement de la sécurité sociale
qui évoquait aussi le mode de
financement de la branche on voit bien
que structurellement la branche famille
excédentaire donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
que cette excédent qui décide là ça
déborde tout à fait mon domaine de
compétence mais je crois que vous avez
tous les éléments pour discuter de ça
alors sur les évolutions par rage il y a
une évolution majeure c'est-à-dire l'âge
moyen en première enfant il était de 24
ans au début des années 1970 et il est
maintenant alors plutôt à 29 ans pour
les premiers enfants et c'est le 31 ans
pour tous les rangs confondus donc ça
fait 5 ans d'augmentation donc d'abord
en termes de conséquences
individuellement plus on commence à
avoir les enfantins plus on a de chances
d'en avoir peu parce que on peut changer
d'avis mais à l'échelle de la population
on a 50 ans de retard de naissance avec
de décalage et on n'a pas de changement
du niveau de la fécondité et quand on
compare les pays européens entre eux
aujourd'hui les pays où on fait des
enfants tard sont plutôt des pays où on
fait beaucoup d'enfants parce que pour
dire les choses très brutalement les
jeunes arrêtent de faire des enfants
alors est-ce que c'est parce qu'ils sont
en situation fragile ou est-ce que c'est
parce qu'ils veulent profiter de la vie
avant de faire des enfants et de
s'engager et ça en tout cas la fécondité
des jeunes baisse partout et puis est-ce
que cette baisse est compensée ou non
par une fécondité aux âgées là ce sont
plutôt beaucoup plus les questions de
conciliation entre vie familiales et vie
professionnelle et donc effectivement
vous l'avez dit c'est important de le
signaler le fait en France d'avoir une
école à trois ans où tous les enfants
vont depuis tôt le matin jusqu'à tard
dans l'après-midi ça permet de concilier
le fait d'avoir deux emplois à temps
plein dans un couple ou bien pour une
femme qui élève seule ses enfants de
travailler en ayant des enfants à
l'école donc ça c'est un élément qui est
très important et ces deux phénomènes
sont un peu indépendants mais
globalement ce qu'on observe en pierre
avec moi c'est que les pays où la
fécondité a été le plus retardé sont
plutôt les pays où la fécondité c'est le
plus maintenue et dans les pays d'Europe
de l'Est ou du Sud alors du Sud c'est
moins vrai mais dans l'épiderme de l'Est
la fécondité n'a pas beaucoup l'âge n'a
pas beaucoup augmenté par contre la
fécondité à beaucoup baissé parce que la
fécondité des jeunes a baissé comme
partout mais comme les conditions de
considération sont extrêmement
difficiles et bien la fécondité des
moins jeunes n'a pas augmenté
donc
au niveau d'ailleurs ça me il y avait
aussi des questions sur les problèmes de
stérilité de recours à la PMA là aussi
on peut dire d'un point de vue
individuel c'est très important il y a
un recours qui est très croissant mais à
l'échelle de la population l'impact de
la PMA sur le nombre total des
naissances et très faible d'abord parce
qu'il y a pas beaucoup de coupes qui ont
recours ensuite parmi les couples qui
ont recours il y en a pas beaucoup qui
arrivent à avoir des enfants et ensuite
il y a peut-être un effet indirect
négatif qui fait que les coupes
sinusionnent sur la possibilité d'avoir
des couples et donc retard encore
davantage leurs enfants et encore une
fois l'échelle individuelle le retard
est porteur d'un risque même si on
retrouve pas ce lien à l'échelle de la
population
alors
sur je vais peut-être m'arrêter là
puisque Christelle a évoqué des choses
sur le
la politique familiale et le lien avec
la fécondité donc bon évidemment la
politique sociale et familiale un de ces
buts qui est de moins en moins explicite
mais qui reste présent en France c'est
d'augmenter le nombre de naissances mais
il y a quand même d'autres buts de la
politique familiale et donc mesurer la
politique familiale uniquement au nombre
d'enfants qui naissent ça paraît quand
même assez
partielle comme mode
d'évaluation donc peut-être tu veux dire
quelque chose sur le vieillissement
ce que je peux dire en lien avec avec le
vieillissement c'est qu'on met souvent
en regard en fait l'idée de la baisse de
la fécondité et de l'influence que ça va
avoir sur les aidants informels en cas
de situation de dépendance on dit ça va
être une catastrophe parce que les
familles vont avoir moins d'enfants et
donc une réserve des dents potentielles
parmi les enfants très importantes donc
je voudrais juste apporter quelques
correctifs là-dessus en termes de
perspective même si on peut encore pas
vraiment planifier parce que ça dépend
beaucoup des comportements
qui ont tendance à beaucoup se
diversifier dans les générations qui
sont en train de vieillir aujourd'hui
dont nous faisons tous partie donc
plusieurs éléments le premier c'est que
la plus grosse majorité des aidants
informels comme on dit donc non
professionnel sont d'abord les conjoints
et que à ce stade les projections
démographiques montr que
il y a encore du fait de l'augmentation
de l'espérance de vie des hommes ces
dernières années
beaucoup plus de couples qui
vieillissent ensemble qu'auparavant donc
il y a une réserve d'aidant par le
conjoint un peu plus importantes même si
les femmes ont tendance à plus aider
leur conjoint homme que que l'inverse le
deuxième élément c'est que des études de
Liné aussi Roméo fontaine ont montré que
la taille des fratries finalement était
pas un élément déterminant que des
aidants il y en a souvent un ou deux y
compris dans des fratries importantes et
que donc le fait qu'une famille se
réduise de 4 à 3 ou de 3 à 2 enfants
n'accepte pas tellement la réserve des
dents potentielles qui se trouve
toujours reposée sur un nombre plus
petit que la réserve totale donc de ce
côté là on peut aussi modifier un le
changement le troisième élément c'est
qu'on a des aspirations des personnes
âgées parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
aidants comme si les déterminants de
demander de l'aide à ses enfants ne
dépendaient que de la volonté des
enfants de la disponibilité des enfants
mais ça dépend bien des aider aussi et
que les aider des générations qui
vieillissent aujourd'hui et qui vont
atteindre bientôt des âges auxquels les
risques d'avoir besoin d'aide s'élève
ont des aspirations changeantes et une
relation avec leurs enfants où ils vont
plutôt être dans
le recours à leurs enfants pour un
accompagnement dans les activités
sympathiques de la vie quotidienne et
qu'ils vont plutôt avoir une aspiration
à faire confiance à des professionnels
mais encore faut-il que ce soit des
professionnels
formés et avec une qualité de
l'accompagnement apporter de qualité
enfin bonne qualité mais il y a plutôt
une tendance à se dire qu'on pourrait
avoir une aspiration à avoir une aide
professionnel auprès de soi pour
s'occuper des soins personnels ou des
courses que de dépendre de ses enfants
donc je sais pas si vous aviez en tête
le lien entre fécondité en baisse et
l'accompagnement du vieillissement mais
on reboucle un peu parce que finalement
on voit que
en considère pas
les personnes dépendantes ou en perte
d'autonomie comme un bloc monolithique
qui se
perpétue de génération en génération et
d'année en année c'est vraiment une
population très diverse avec des
comportements de demande d'aide et
d'accompagnement qui va avoir beaucoup
de transformation avec le vieillissement
des baby-boomers aujourd'hui et que dans
ce cadre là il est vraiment très
important de projeter plutôt le besoin
en aide professionnelle de qualité que
de que de regarder quelles vont être les
réserves du côté informel
c'est alors Corinne Imbert Alain Dufour
Annick jacquemais Corinne Imbert merci
de la présidente merci mesdames merci
Monsieur pour vos éclairages je vais
continuer sur l'aspect vieillissement de
la population vous l'avez dit et redit
il est tard du coup il s'impose aux
autorités sanitaires s'impose aussi au
département en termes de prise en charge
des personnes âgées dépendantes
et pour autant nous avons un ministère
de la Santé de la prévention est-ce que
dans vos recherches dans vos travaux
vous avez imaginé quelle politique de
prévention il faudrait pour que ça
impacte l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé
l'espérance de vie d'une manière
générale et l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et puis une question je veux dire
annexe est-ce que vous travaillez avec
vos collègues démographes qui
travaillent au sein de la plateforme
nationale de recherche sur la fin de vie
ou pas je vous remercie
Alain
merci mesdames messieurs merci aussi la
question que je voulais poser c'est de
savoir sur le les prospectives de
vieillissement de la population en
France est-ce que vous avez pu comparer
avec les pays européens
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez
intégrer ce paramètre dans l'évolution
du vieillissement de la population en
France merci
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs dames pour vos exposés j'ai
deux petites questions
madame déjà dans un des premiers
graphiques que vous nous avez montré
dans le scénario central des projections
de la population vous dites que vous
tenez compte bien sûr de la fécondité
est-ce que vous tenez compte aussi du
désir d'enfant parce que ces deux choses
différentes et moi je suis frappée par
tous ces jeunes couples qui justement
disent bah non nous on veut plus
d'enfants on préfère vivre comme ça
parce que il y a l'anxiété parce que il
y a le monde dans quel monde on va les
faire vivre etc donc est-ce que vous
avez tenu compte de ce paramètre ou
c'est uniquement des chiffres factuels
et puis pour monsieur tout le monde j'ai
aussi une question où nous avez montré
un graphique qui comparait justement la
chute de la natalité dans tous les pays
et j'ai noté si j'ai bien vu que
l'Islande l'Irlande les États-Unis l'al
lemagne et l'Espagne avaient une
natalité qui remontait assez
significativement est-ce que vous avez
pu colorer les cette augmentation de la
natalité à certaines dispositions ou
certaines politiques que ces pays-là
auraient mis en oeuvre que ça soit au
niveau de l'accompagnement de la famille
au niveau des conditions de travail etc
merci merci bien alors
je commence je vais je vais essayer
d'être assez rapide juste pour vous
expliquer que la la dépendance la perte
d'autonomie est un processus que je vais
vous expliquer très rapidement pour vous
montrer en quoi la prévention et la
prise en charge
s'articule comment elle s'articule et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut entrevoir donc
c'est l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui proposait un processus où on
partait de la maladie ou de la mauvaise
santé tout à fait à gauche du graphique
et que ces maladies qu'on appelle
parfois invalidantes aujourd'hui on
parle des maladies chroniques
invalidantes donc celle qui laisse des
traces on va dire qu'on ne guérit pas
totalement vont avoir
possiblement des impacts des lésions sur
l'organisme et diminuer certaines
fonctions la dégénérescence maculaire va
avoir un pouvoir limitant sur
pardon sur sur la capacité visuelle et
cette perte de capacité visuelle peut
avoir un impact sur les activités qu'on
fait on ne peut plus conduire on ne peut
plus aller faire ses courses etc selon
les activités qui sont impactées par la
maladie que l'on a ou les déficiences et
limitations fonctionnelles on va être
empêché dans des activités dites
élémentaires donc ce qu'on appelle perte
d'autonomie aujourd'hui c'est quand les
personnes ont besoin d'aide pour des
activités élémentaires faire ses courses
faire sa toilette se nourrir etc donc on
a un lot d'activités qui vont faire que
à partir du moment on a trop de
difficultés et qu'on a besoin de
quelqu'un pour être aidé pour les
réaliser parce qu'on les juge
indispensables on appelle ça de la perte
d'autonomie une petite parenthèse on
pourrait rentrer dans ces activités
élémentaires indispensables les
relations interpersonnelles la
sociabilité accéder à la culture etc
donc la perte elle peut être beaucoup
plus grande que la définition qu'on a
aujourd'hui et donc juste pourquoi je
vous explique ceci parce qu'on le voit
ici la prévention et la prise en charge
s'articule à chacune de ces étapes c'est
à dire que la prévention peut être
d'éviter que des maladies invalidantes
ne surviennent c'est toutes les plans
prévention vers les maladies
neurodégénératives telles Alzheimer
c'est toute cette machine grosse machine
qui est en route la prise en charge
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait des personnes
une fois qu'elles sont rentrées dans ces
dans ces problématiques là et donc on
voit que on peut avoir de la prévention
à chaque étape et quand je parlais tout
à l'heure de l'imitation fonctionnelle
qui vont ou pas avoir des impacts sur
les activités ça va dépendre de
l'environnement dans lequel on est de
son logement mais aussi de sa ville de
satiété l'accessibilité
au service de soins aux espaces
culturels aux espaces
commerciaux etc c'est à dire que
dans la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie on a tout le volet médical
si vous voulez et on a une marge
d'intervention absolument énorme et que
toutes les personnes qui travaillent sur
le vieillissement vraiment invite les
politiques publiques à prendre en compte
c'est tout ce qui est non pas des
politiques de bien vieillir mais plutôt
de revenir à l'intitulé d'avant
c'est-à-dire de s'adapter d'adapter la
société au vieillissement de la
population et ça passe par ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure la configuration
des logements la configuration des
villes prendre en compte le fait que
notre société connaît un vieillissement
inéluctable et que on n'est pas à se
demander comment on lutte contre ce
vieillissement comme on l'entend parfois
mais plutôt comment on réorganise
l'espace de vie et les politiques
publiques pour que des personnes y
compris lorsqu'elles sont atteintes de
pathologies parce que le vieillissement
biologique expose parce que la
vulnérabilité sociale explose plus assez
risques comment y compris avec des
problèmes fonctionnels de vue de
mobilité
de de oui comment on organise une
société pour que on ne soit pas dans un
agissement et dans une isolement social
des personnes avec ses limitations
fonctionnelles donc beaucoup à faire du
côté à la fois de la prise en charge et
de la prévention médicale et
d'aménagement de la société en général
et on parle beaucoup de la prévention
mais il faut surtout pas oublier la
prise en charge des personnes qui n'ont
pas pu prévenir
les restrictions d'activité et donc il
faut aussi avoir une politique de
qualité d'accompagnement des personnes
bien pour le reste alors qui répond sur
désir d'enfant
comparaison européenne
merci oui donc il existe en effet des
projections démographiques dans les
différents pays européens donc sous les
gîtes de rostade l'office statistique
des Communautés européennes qui donc
j'ai pas le détail la pays par pays mais
on pourra vous envoyer des éléments en
complémentaires les tendances qui ont
que j'ai présenté elles sont un peu
partout et puis si on regarde la
population de l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne un peu comme en France il y a
un moment elle atteint un pic et ensuite
ça diminue et il y a un vieillissement
donc avec une pyramide des âges aussi
qui
s'élargit en haut et qui se diminue en
bas donc ça ce sont des tendances assez
générales après il y a des variations
selon les pays parce que les niveaux de
fécondité et la structure parage
aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie aussi
sont assez différentes mais grosso modo
c'est un schéma un peu en tout cas au
niveau de l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne c'est un retrouve l'écran de
tendance après si vous voulez plus de
détails on pourra vous vous envoyer des
compléments un peu sur la diversité des
situations dans
dans les différents pays
voilà alors nous on mesure pas alors sur
la fécondité sur la fécondité voilà sur
la fécondité dans les projections
démographiques il faut dire voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on met comme un disque
conjoncturel de fécondité et surtout
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on dans le futur donc
il y a eu pas mal de débats on a fait
des consultations d'experts consultés
par exemple Monsieur Laurent tout le
monde au titre des experts et d'autres
experts à la fois français et étrangers
et il y a eu un peu de débat en fait au
sein des experts sur donc
l'indice conjoncturel de fécondité il
reste comme leur montrer les graphiques
tout à l'heure assez élevé en France
voilà mais il a tendance à décroître
depuis voilà et donc là on est à 1,8
enfin par femme et on s'est dit bon
est-ce que on va vers la moyenne
européenne par exemple est-ce qu'on
pense qu'il peut remonter parce que au
début des années 2000 on était plus près
de deux est-ce qu'on pense qu'il va
rester à peu près stable où il a diminué
mais on est à peu près voilà et donc il
y a eu des positions autant sur la
mortalité il y avait des positions assez
convergentes sur la fécondité il y avait
des positions plus contrastées
en lien par exemple avec les facteurs
que vous avez évoqué notamment de
crainte face à l'avenir voilà très
clairement que l'on mesure pas très bien
enfin voilà
c'est difficile de d'avoir de mesurer
vraiment l'impact de des craintes face à
l'avenir qu'elles soient liées au
changement climatique ou à d'autres
d'autres choses mais voilà c'est là où
il y a eu plus de débats finalement donc
nous avons retenu une hypothèse qui
était quand même majoritaire parmi les
experts mais pas
pas c'était pas 100% qui disait ça de et
on a maintenu à 1,8 enfants parfum dans
le scénario central après on a aussi un
scénario de fécité fécondité basse à 1,6
enfin par femme voilà et un scénario de
fécondité haute ou on remettrait à deux
voilà ce qui permet aussi de voir
l'impact de cette fécondité et donc si
on a des scénarios différents le voir
l'impact sur la population en fonction
des différences scénarios mais dans le
scénario central finalement on a fait ce
choix
alors à la Milan s'est inscrit pour
Alain tu veux peut-être compléter
merci merci pour toutes ces informations
mesdames messieurs mesdames messieurs
c'est assez quand même inquiétant de
voir cette baisse de fécondité je suis
étonné d'ailleurs de l'avoir aussi en
Islande alors que jusqu'à présent
l'Islande paraissait comme étant un pays
un pays où on était assez forte cette
constatation vous faites vous les faites
pour l'Europe vous les faites pour les
États-Unis est-ce que vous faites les
mêmes constatations pour l'Amérique
latine pour l'Afrique ou pour les pays
asiatiques est-ce que vous avez des
des graphiques sur ce sujet et les
études que vous avez faites vous
montrent-elles qui a des problèmes de
physiologie peut-être quelque part ou
des problèmes de fertilité en
particulier de fertilité masculine dont
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler il y a un
certain temps en arrière
alors je vais essayer d'être bref sur
toutes ces questions donc d'abord moi
aussi je vais commencer par la fin sur
les aspects de fertilité masculine de
qualité du sperme il y a d'une part une
détérioration du nombre de
spermatozoïdes dans le sperme qu'on
constate dans beaucoup de pays avec très
probablement un lien avec des questions
de pollution de perturbateurs
endocriniens ça c'est tout à fait établi
par contre la relation avec le niveau de
fécondité dans les pays où l'évolution
n'est pas du tout établie nulle part
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas de relation
empirique pour le moment alors peut-être
que ça va arriver à l'avenir mais on
peut dire que aujourd'hui et c'est vrai
à l'échelle du monde
l'état sanitaire de la population a
plutôt tendance à s'améliorer bon même
si dans les années toute récente il y a
des difficultés dans certaines régions
du monde mais globalement on est plutôt
dans une situation d'amélioration
non seulement de la durée de vie mais
aussi de l'état de santé des des adultes
alors sur les projections dans les
autres continents on va la situation est
très contrastée on peut dire il y a des
pays notamment en Asie de l'Est on parle
souvent de Taïwan ou de la Corée ou la
fécondité inférieure à un enfant par
femme donc là les perspectives de long
terme c'est une population qui est
divisée par deux tous les 30 ans donc il
est divisé par 8 en un siècle donc il y
a une espèce de crainte du vide qui est
très forte et il y a une il y a des
politiques familiales qui sont souvent
très forts très volontariste mais qui
n'ont aucun effet parce que elle s'encre
dans un contexte très conservateur et
pour dire les choses brutalement moi
j'ai entendu des jeunes femmes
politiques se battre avec des vieux
hommes politiques donc les derniers
reprocher aux jeunes femmes de plus
vouloir faire d'enfant et les jeunes
femmes disaient ben c'est pas difficile
si on fait des enfants on arrête d'être
des êtres humains on doit s'occuper des
proches on doit obéir au mari on ne peut
plus tandis que si on n'a pas d'enfant
on continue à avoir une place dans la
société en tant que adulte et le
problème c'est que si on veut pas avoir
d'enfant il faut pas se marier si on va
pas se marier il faut pas vivre en
couple parce que il y a un mécanisme de
pression sociale qui fait que c'est très
difficile d'être en couple sans être
marié c'est très difficile d'être sans
être en couple et donc la solution c'est
de ne pas vivre en couple alors bon dieu
merci il y a quand même des relations
intimes ou sexuelles indépendamment des
couples mais quand même il y a un choix
qui est très radical c'est le Hoptown
c'est-à-dire la seule solution c'est de
ne pas vivre en couple parce que sinon
c'est un piège alors que on voit et dans
les pays d'Europe ou dans les pays
développés on voit que les pays où la
société est la plus fluide où les
systèmes familiaux sont les plus divers
ou les situations sont les plus
diversifiées
sont ceux où la fécondité la plus élevée
je me souviens de discussion que que
j'avais eu avec des représentants de
l'Église catholique qui était tout à
fait étonné de voir que la
l'autorisation pour les coupes de même
sexe de se marier c'est plutôt favorable
à la fécondité alors évidemment à
l'échelle individuelle on peut dire ils
sont perdus pour la patrie ceux qui sont
en couple de même sexe alors c'est de
moins en moins vrai les chaînes
individuelles mais à l'échelle de la
population la relation est plutôt dans
l'autre sens et alors janvier en
question de politique familiales vous
disiez il y a des pays où ça monte et
puis ça monte pas en France bon en fait
il faut voir là il y a deux choses
importantes c'est en Allemagne et en
Hongrie les pays qui étaient en bas et
les pays qui étaient en dessous de 1,4
il y a ce qu'on appelle la le risque de
fécondité basse de long terme les gens
prennent l'habitude de ne plus avoir
d'enfants et du coup il y a un modèle
avec beaucoup de personnes sans enfant
beaucoup de petites familles et
l'Allemagne depuis des années 2000 à une
politique très volontariste de création
de place de crèche avec des difficultés
importantes encore créer des crèches à
partir de rien c'est possible mais faire
que les écoles soient pas seulement le
matin mais toute la journée ça veut dire
construire des cantines et qu'on soit
des cantines quand vous avez une école
dans une ville avec des voisins qui
veulent pas trop de nuisances c'est un
problème très très compliqué en
Allemagne un des grands problèmes de la
petite familiale c'est de permettre aux
parents de travailler en permettant aux
enfants de ne pas rentrer chez eux pour
déjeuner donc vous voyez qu'en France on
est très loin de ces questions là mais
ça n'empêche que après 10 ans de alors
s'il y a eu un effet mais avec 10 ans de
retard donc les Allemands expliquent ça
par un mécanisme donc je vous épargne le
détail en Hongrie il y a aussi une
politique très volontariste d'aide aux
familles mais dans une société qui est
assez autoritaire par contre en Italie
en Espagne il y a pas de politique
familiale il a fécondité reste très
basse et dans les autres pays dans les
pays du Nord alors là les discussions il
y a un discours qui correspond à ce que
vous dites déco anxiété les jeunes
veulent soit y profiter de la vie soit
ils ont peur de l'avenir il y a eu aussi
un afflublissement de la politique
sociale dans beaucoup de pays en Suède
notamment il y a eu un peu une
catastrophe industrielle avec la
privatisation de l'éducation le fait de
laisser les parents libres de leur choix
éducatifs c'est-à-dire ils ont un budget
pour l'éducation de leurs enfants ils
font ceux qui veulent et du coup ça a un
peu détruit l'école publique et ça pour
certains chercheurs de Suède ça a été un
élément très important parce que cette
perspective en France même si
l'éducation reste très inégalitaire en
France
il y a l'idée que c'est à l'état de
prendre en charge les enfants
par exemple en Allemagne quand on n'a
pas de quoi se le payer c'est considéré
comme immoral d'avoir beaucoup d'enfants
alors qu'en France personne ça viendra à
l'idée de personnes de reprocher à
quelqu'un de faire un troisième enfant
alors que déjà le deuxième par pas en
vacances ça paraîtrait presque
insupportable donc on voit que le la
politique elle s'inscrit dans un
contexte et donc dans ce cadre-là les
évolutions de court terme qu'on voit il
faut se méfier bon par exemple en
Islande on est passé de 2,2 à 1,7 donc
le fait qu'il y a un petit rebond c'est
quelque chose qu'on observe souvent
quand il y a un changement massif il y a
souvent un petit rebond mais c'est
difficile de l'expliquer par un
changement de la politique familiale de
même la baisse récente en Allemagne qui
est très importante je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure elle est plutôt interprétée par
des relations avec des petites
vaccinales donc nous ça nous paraît un
peu étrange dont je crois qu'il faut
faire attention de pas interpréter des
changements
immédiats des comportements de fécondité
à l'aune des politiques qui sont plutôt
encore une fois quand on fait un enfant
on en prend pour 20 ans ou voire plus et
donc
c'est pas forcément les changements
immédiats qui vont qui vont changer les
comportements
voilà et un dernier mot sur la
proportion de personnes sans enfant
quand même en France il y a une
augmentation de la part des personnes
sans enfant mais d'une part le niveau
est plus faible et d'autre part la
hausse est beaucoup plus modérée que
dans d'autres pays et on a beaucoup
moins en France l'idée que être un
adulte accompli sans avoir d'enfants
mais en ayant d'autres contributions
d'espèces humaines c'est tout à fait
raisonnable et licite en France il y a
une pression pour les gens quand un
couple et ensemble depuis cinq ou six
ans et qui a pas d'enfance demande s'il
y a un problème médical aussi un
problème de mésentente enfin ça la
pression sociale reste très forte et du
coup même si on sort d'une période très
très exceptionnelle des des années 70 ou
les générations qui se sont battues pour
la maîtrise de la fécondité par la
contraception et l'avortement sont des
générations ou pratiquement aucune aucun
habitant à choisi de rester sans enfant
et là on retrouve une situation un peu
moins extrait extrême disons mais avec
des taux d'infécondité qui sont de
l'ordre de peut-être 15% des femmes qui
restent sans enfant peut-être un peu
plus pour les hommes bon là avec les
reconstitutions familiales avec les
reconnaissances d'enfance ça devient un
peu compliqué déjà de savoir qui sont
des personnes qui ont des enfants qui
sont ceux qui n'en ont pas mais
globalement ce qu'on peut retenir c'est
qu'en France il y a une stabilité des
comportements de fécondité même s'il y a
une baisse depuis 2014 et il y a aussi
une baisse beaucoup plus modérée
qu'ailleurs de la proportion des
personnes qui n'ont aucun enfant
merci beaucoup donc on transmettra au
collègues les éléments que vous nous
avez donné merci beaucoup je pense que
c'est important qu'on fasse ce point
parce qu'on dans nos décisions on est
souvent on a quelques
données démographiques mais c'est
important qu'on puisse voir cette
évolution donc merci beaucoup ça pose
plein de questions auxquelles on n'a pas
pu répondre ce matin et on n'a pas posé
toutes les questions
qui pourraient venir mais merci beaucoup
à tous les trois de cet échange